alors attention l'ogre dort profondément
dans les dépendances du château de
breteuil une toute nouvelle scénographie
est à découvrir dans l'ancien four à
pain le conte du petit poucet de charles
perrault il y racontait un travail de
six mois pour le scénographe
[Musique]
dans cette scène il y a plein de
particularités déjà vous avez trois
vidéos projections qui se répondent vous
avez d'abord le visage de charles
perrault qui parlent directement au
public donc là on a imprimé le visage
d'un comédien ont l'impression 3d vous
avez aussi des images aériennes un film
et avec un drone vous avez aussi au
niveau des particularités un ogre qui
est immense qui fait trois mètres de
haut et cet ordre est bien du coup il
est créé sur mesure pour la scène du
château de breteuil donc un visage en
silicone démence illico les bottes qu'on
a réalisé en interne au château de
bretagne qui font un mètre vingt deux
auteurs qui sont en plâtre et puis dans
le décor beaucoup de détails parce que
le souci du détail est important les
spectateurs vont suivre les aventures du
petit poucet incarné par un comédien
on a ouvert un casting au grand public
donc on a eu 36 petit poucet qui se sont
présentés et on a choisi un yvelinois un
rambolitains précisément qui s'appelle
donovan le bourhis qui avait sept ans au
moment du tournage il lui manquait sa
tente devant et puis surtout il avait
beaucoup d'espoir glory beaucoup de
naturel une autre scène de compte a été
rénové peau d'âne dans l'ancien la voir
comment une souillon comment moi cachée
sous cette poule dan a vu conquérir
legarda prince
ah les six mois à compter mon histoire
on est plutôt dans une scène qui a été
recréée repensé et modernisé
l'idée c'est que toute la scénographie
s'articule autour d'un court métrage qui
s'intègre vraiment dans le décor de cet
ancien lavoir avec des accessoires
d'antan et la fameuse peau d'âne un
coffre magique et les fameuses robes
robes couleur du temps de lune et le
soleil
d'une durée de 5 minutes la scénographie
de peau d'âne a demandé deux mois de
travail pour découvrir ces deux
nouvelles scènes de compte le château de
breteuil est ouvert tous les jours y
compris le 1er et le 8 mai